- I don't give a fuck!
Hey Ardy the fat ass,
you're gonna be a great chef
but get the fuck off the football field!
You suck!
(techno music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(dynamic music)
- Good morning.
- Morning
- Thanks for coming.
- Thanks for having me.
- Yeah, to your place.
- Yes.
- Yeah, really cool.
It's really far from
Montclair, New Jersey, though.
- I'm aware.
- Yeah, but -
- I always get excited when
somebody gets transferred
from Hudson Yards to
here and lives in Jersey.
We find out their true grit.
- Definitely.
First of all, I just
heard about your new show
- Trash Talk.
- and it sounds unbelievable.
So tell us how Trash Talk came
and you don't really need
the cash, I don't think.
So, explain to me what drives you.
- No, I am not spending my
entire Saturday to make $613.
I'm not sure if there's any
place I'm happier in the world,
than when I am actively
garage sailing in New Jersey
at 8:13 in the morning, on a Saturday.
I love garage sailing, here's
what's really driving me.
An enormous amount of people follow me,
who disproportionately are affected
by making $100 to $500 more a month.
Like that means -
- Right.
something for real.
- All of my homies in contemporaries
are telling these people
to build the next Facebook.
I'm practical.
I know that anybody who's
listening right now,
who genuinely needs an extra
100 bucks a week, the easiest,
and I don't use, by the
way, I hate the word easy.
The easiest way to make
100 bucks extra a week,
is to go to thrift stores,
Goodwill, garage sales,
buy things and sell them on eBay, OfferUp.
Just try it for a little
while, see if you can do it.
I do think that the
average skilled person,
after a couple months, gets
to 20 or 30 bucks an hour.
- But when it comes to sports
and especially when you're a kid,
I mean being a mom that watched my kids
- Yes
- and all the different sports
and yes, if you get fourth place
and fifth and whatever place,
it's a little bit of a confidence builder.
It's like, okay -
- I'm outta here.
- Okay.
- I'm , Bobby...
- You have to
- Bobby!
- There's some , chubby, fat
kid, who's like barely makin -
- Who needs to understand,
yo chubby fat kid,
you're not gonna be a
professional fuckin athlete.
Go be a great fuckin architect.
- You're in third grade.
- I don't give a fuck.
- Hey Ardy, the fat ass,
you're gonna be a great chef
but get the fuck off the football field.
You suck.
- But I just think everyone's
good at something...
- That's right, so get off
the fuckin football field
but guess what, mommy Bobby
over here is tricking you
and making you think you might be okay.
- No.
- Yes.
- No, no, no
- Yes, yes yes.
- Is his microphone louder than mine
or does he just talk louder?
I'm trying to figure it out.
- I'm fuckin pissed out here.
Like, you're a fuckin gangster winner
and this is what I'm worried about.
Bobby, there's a reason that
people are struggling mentally
and I'm telling you, everybody
wants to blame social media.
It's bullshit, it's parents,
creating fake environments for children.
We're building zoo animals.
It means when you take a
tiger from the Bronx Zoo
and you put it in the actual jungle,
he fuckin or she dies in one second
because they've not grown up
in the actual environment.
You take kids who fuckin
think they're good at baseball
because in Montclair up
until fuckin 12th grade,
everybody's fuckin good
and then you actually go
and play baseball and
you get fuckin struck-out
900 times in a row.
You go back to your dorm room
and start doing fuckin cocaine.
- Oh, come on Gary, it
doesn't work like that
- That's exactly...
- It does not.
- My -
- Whoa, listen.
- Does not
- Listen.
You look at the kids' faces, they're all -
- Did you play baseball?
- [Audience Member] No, I played football.
- No, football, okay.
- He did fuckin cocaine.
- No, if you're not good at football
and you love the sport,
so go work for the team.
Like there's ways to take your passion.
- Okay, keep going, keep building.
- No, but it's true.
I watched my kids, I had a pro golfer,
I had kids that were
good at different things
and then they weren't anymore.
You know, they entered high school,
you know there were on traveling soccer
and baseball their entire careers
until they went to high school.
They realized, they're not gonna make it.
- That's right.
- And they didn't.
So they moved on.
- That's fine, and listen, a
lot of people don't move on.
- Yeah.
- And creating fake
environments is an issue
that needs to be talked about much more.
Fake environments doesn't mean like mean
it means just don't create delusion.
- So you give advice all the time.
If there's one thing you
could tell people right now
to do, right now, that
will change the course
of their life, one thing.
- Communicate the poison
that's in their head
to the person that needs to hear it.
(dynamic music)
(siren)
- [Greeter] Hello.
How are you?
- Good to see ya.
It's a pleasure, thanks for being here.
I want you to be super selfish
and ask exact question that you want
because that's what we're here for
and that's what my part is about.
It's been fun when, you know,
didn't know how that would play out
but it's, you know, it's
remarkable obviously.
Many very different businesses,
different life cycles.
But, it's amazing how
there's always something
to take from somebody asks us questions.
So, I'm glad you guys are here.
Thank you guys.
Good to see you again bro.
Thanks a lot guys, take care.
(dynamic music)
- [Video] Hello, you are
on the AskGaryVee Show,
with Asher Woreat.
- Oh my goodness, no way.
This is so crazy.
- You have any idea what the odds
of actually becoming human are?
400 trillion to one, you
could've been a tree.
It would suck if I was a tree.
Trees can't do anything.
Gratitude, got it.
(dynamic music)
- Yo.
We need more of that kind of stuff.
- [Announcer] And his name is John Cena.
(upbeat music)
(dynamic music)
- How are you?
- G.V.
- Good to see you man.
How you been?
What's up man?
- How you doin, man?
- Real pleasure, what's your name?
Clay?
- Yeah.
- Nice to meet ya.
Sit, sit, sit.
Is there anything I can help with?
- He just asked the question,
what you think about the
agency and stuff like that?
- I think if you wanna,
like, if you're like,
this is how I think.
The world's crazy now, like,
when I go on stage, I'm like
this is the best era to be alive.
People are like, ah Trump,
and I understand it,
and they're not wrong,
there's plenty of fucked up shit.
You made a fuckin video on a...
People don't get it, like
that's not how it went down.
Like, I'm old, you used to have to get,
you gotta move to fuckin Hollywood.
Wait tables and be the one
black dude they picked,
out of everyone there.
It's real wild and if you're a youngster,
you don't have context, you don't know.
But, like I got it real good
cause I'm old enough to know
but young enough to still
wanna do something about it.
And then you got people that are like,
this is why 80 year olds are
like these fuckin, you know.
So, couple things, if you
really wanna have like
a Netflix special or like
straight up, you're like fuck it,
I wanna make like Friday,
you need a fuckin agent.
- Okay.
- What do you think that they bring?
They bring I guess the production -
- They're gatekeepers.
- Yeah.
- They don't bring anything but the keys.
Right?
They put him together with somebody
who really knows how to make movies.
They hit it off and they
make a fuckin, you know,
Beverly Hills Cop, let's go.
It's just kinda like that, it's
just kinda crazy like that.
If that's what you wanna do.
If you wanna do, like, that's
what's crazy about music.
How far you can now go.
In film, you can't.
Like nobody, you can't
point me to the movie
that's like the big
blockbuster on YouTube, yet.
I believe that will happen.
I believe the same way Netflix happened,
I believe like, you could
wait, and make your own comedy,
raise money, make something amazing.
And in 12, 15 years, I
think what Netflix is,
is gonna be long-tail,
there'll be more of them.
Things like them, the way
internet works, right?
Even the way people watch the
shit, I don't know if you saw,
but I'm like obsessed with garage sailing.
People are watching my shit,
people are taking pictures
of them watching it.
They're watching it on their main TV
cause everybody now knows how to put
YouTube from their phone to the TV.
Grandma doesn't but you do.
And so like, when that
happens, well then let's go.
Like you can do your own stand up special.
Rent out a fuckin place,
have people come, film it
and you can do your own raw
and you've got a big enough audience.
Like I'd pay $3.99 for you.
You know, like that kinda shit.
So it's all coming, the
problem is your moment's now.
- [Shiggy] Yeah, exactly right.
- Right?
So you have to give up
some of the money, right?
To like, continue it, if
that's what you wanna do.
Or, you keep building momentum.
You keep, I'm watching
you, you keep tryna...
What's great about being creative is,
you could think of something tomorrow,
post it and you got a shot.
And I do think this,
I do think if you have a second meme
of real scale, it'd put you
in totally different place.
- [Shiggy] Yeah I know.
- I would really give a fuck
about being strategic
about your next move.
But I wouldn't be crippled by it either.
You don't need to.
Like if you put too much pressure,
that I gotta nail this next thing,
you're gonna get in the wrong mindset.
You need to be thoughtful,
but you need to not
overthink your creativity.
It's how you got here in the first place.
- Yeah, just doin regular shit.
- Just doin regular shit.
That's a real good way to put it.
- Always, I love employing friends.
But, since I was always top dog,
I've always told friends,
I'll fire you, I swear.
Because I'll help you get a job better
but you can't fuck up the thing.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And like you can't be entitled.
And like I'm a human, and I may be wrong.
Boyd, like I may decide that
Boyd's better than D-Rock.
I may be wrong, but this is my shit.
You can go do your shit.
So if you wanna be employed here,
I'm gonna try my best, I got love,
I wanna all die together but yeah.
We started this company
with like seven friends.
I took my assistant from Wine
Library, the only person.
And it was like six of AJ's friends,
and we started.
Cool.
(dynamic music)
- Gary
- Sebastian
- How are you?
- Congrats on everything.
- No, congratulations to you.
Thank you for having us, this is amazing.
Hi, how are you?
Nice to meet you, man.
- A lot of people get fearful
of like actually going
where they need to go
cause they got success somewhere else.
It's the biggest mistake.
- 100%.
- Authenticity always wins.
- 100%, it's a -
- It's why I'm considering
taking Garage Sale full-time.
- You love garage sales?
- More than breathing.
- Are you serious?
- Yes.
- What are you gonna
sell me right now, bro?
- What do you want?
I got all sorts of shit.
- I don't know, let's do some business.
- You want a rare Michael
Buble signed album?
- Of course I want -
(laughing)
- If we did a national
commercial with you,
that leaned into your sex appeal
but in a clever way, it would explode.
I have the concept, that's my concept.
I think it will lean in, it
will be very good for you,
cause it will like be a, it's almost like,
a big company saying, got it.
It'll work, I just now have
to think about the brand
and the creative idea that's
clever to lean in to it.
But it will fuckin work.
(dynamic music)
- Hey guys, it's Danielle
Snyder with No Filter.
This is episode six with my favorite Gary,
that's not my dad.
- That's right.
- What up Gary Vaynerchuk?
- Things are amazing.
Congrats on all the mitzvahs in your life
and I'm super excited to be here.
- What is the worst pitch
that's ever come to you?
Where you were just like actually,
can I pull out my like
recording device to record that?
- You know what's funny?
It's amazing that nothing populated.
On the flip side, almost all of them.
We live in a a completely
delusional world,
where people think their ideas
worth seven million dollars.
- But how much is it really the idea
versus the person behind the idea
that's gonna morph it into whatever?
- Its the person behind it.
- Right?
- 100%
- Is there anything else we wanted to ask
that we didn't ask yet?
- [Crew Member] Kanye West.
What are your thoughts on Kanye West?
- Happy to answer.
- What are your thoughts on Kanye West?
Cindy sent me some questions.
I don't know, what are
your thoughts on Kanye...
- This is super easy for me.
To Kanye's credit, I get asked this a lot
and it's super easy for me to answer.
- [Danielle] Does he follow you?
- No.
- Do you want him to follow you?
- Of course, I want every single person
on earth to follow me.
I don't have, here's what I would say.
Kanye and I share an, and
Taylor Swift and many others,
Zucks, have a very similar skills set
which is we understand human behavior
and what garners attention and we all...
- Attention Arbitrage.
- That's right.
And we all do it very,
very, very differently.
Truth is, I don't know.
So I'll explain.
All I know about Kanye is the blips.
Like I don't follow him, I
don't consume his content.
I haven't heard any of
his last three albums
cause he fuckin put it on Tidal.
So I don't know what's
going on musically, at all.
I don't, it's a very easy
answer for me, I don't know.
I don't know what he's truly thinking.
I don't think he's trolling.
Everyone who's like, he's
just doing this for attention,
doesn't, intuitively, I don't think so.
But, you know like what's
super interesting is,
the things he brings up,
that I've hit by accident,
there's a lot of intriguing
thought in the process
of what he's doing and so,
it's super interesting to watch from afar.
But I haven't, I've almost
purposely not allowed myself
to dig in deep enough to
form an educated opinion a),
because I don't dig into
anything like that, content wise.
So for example, you'll appreciate this.
This is actually how my brain works.
My opinions on Kanye are predicated
on the hundreds of thousands of comments
about Kanye more than what
Kanye's actually doing.
My big move, normally, when
something hits my site guys,
Stranger Things is a big show,
oh weird, okay.
I'll go to Stranger Things,
Instagram or YouTube or Twitter
but I won't see what they're doing,
I'll read everything that
people have to say about it.
I literally read, I wanna actually,
I've been throwing around a lot
of numbers, I wanna nail it.
Man, I read a lot, I read
thousands of comments
about Cardi B before I allowed myself
to even listen to a single song.
- And?
- Oh, I love the way she story tells.
But I really like consuming
people's reactions
more than the content
that sparks the reaction.
I really do.
That's why I think I'm good at America.
I really understand America
cause I consume America's
reactions to everything.
(Dynamic music)